the coronavirus may be new but it's
triggering something downright primal
and many of us fear and anxiety
psychiatrist and author Gil Saul says
the outbreak has all the features that
would typically arouse such emotions and
she joins us to tell us just how to
handle them and how to talk to our kids
most importantly gale good morning good
morning a lot of folks are really
anxious about this questioning
everything how long will this last do I
need to stay put I mean what do you
suggest to people and how they handle
this mentally and emotionally first of
all I think people need to understand
that what they're feeling is normal you
know a pathologizing or making yourself
feel even worse about why am I so
completely freaked out
it's not helpful and it's not true it is
normal to be feeling anxious now because
this is a there are some dangerous
things going on and we have an
evolutionary built-in system to react
with anxiety to alert us to things that
we should avoid and be concerned about
so it's normal but there is for many
people this feeling of lack of control
and the scariness that has health
concerns involved and so there are a
number of things that one can do to feel
that you have more control in this
situation and that will help with the
anxiety and those are following the
directions that expert health advisors
have suggested you know have your Purell
have some be stocked up on things do
your social distancing do the things
that feel like problem-solving but
beyond that you really want to do some
things to reduce anxiety in general and
things that really help with anxiety for
example our daily aerobic exercise of
some sort you can do that in your home
you can do that in your apartment you
can do it outside when you aren't around
other people and and doing aerobic
exercise reduces stress reduces anxiety
level I would suggest that most people
take their news alerts off their phone
take things that are gonna zing you on
an hourly basis with some sort of
information much of which you don't need
some of which is incorrect and pick one
source
for example CDC gov that you get the
information that you do need on a once a
day maybe twice a day basis but
repeatedly having the news actually
Stokes many people and that's really not
helpful in terms of your anxiety pay
attention to have regular sleep if you
are staying home which many people are
doing now set up a structure for
yourself get up at a regular time don't
stay in your PJs all day put on your
clothes do you do your work set up a
workspace that feels comfortable to you
that feels more structured to you create
a schedule
sorry I didn't want to interrupt you but
that's where I wanted to go next
actually a lot of people are home now
more than they ever expected to be with
people that they're not usually home
with all the time their families this is
a very changing routine how can people
try to adjust to some of that because
that alone produces anxiety in those
close borders it does I mean we're
social creatures and bonding is actually
a way that we reduce our anxieties so
first I want to say to people that yes
you may need to be home to social
distance but stay in touch with people
that you normally stay in touch with so
this is the case where social media and
other methods of using the internet and
your phone are helpful you want to have
conversations with family with friends
with coworkers so continue that
conversation to stay bonded and talk
about how you're feeling if that makes
you feel better but as I was saying
earlier create a structure in your day
so set up your your desk somewhere not
at the kitchen table preferably but
somewhere that feels reasonable that you
get work done and have a time that you
get up have a time that you have laid
out that you do your various things take
a break to do some exercise take a break
to consider doing a relaxation technique
this is very useful for people that
don't do it already
now's a good time to start there are
many apps that allow you to practice
mindfulness or other sorts of relaxation
techniques you can do this with the
people that are in the home now with you
that's right apologies for interrupting
here doctor but I just want us one more
thing quickly
we don't have much time when you're
talking to kids about this how much
should you do that how do you handle
that
kids take their cue from you so if you
can establish the structure the calm the
routines they will take their cue from
you and answer their questions of course
as they have them don't volunteer more
information than frankly they're
developed that's developmentally
appropriate or that they're asking for
and if you can stay not I'm fairly calm
but you know I really we got this we're
gonna get through this and this is the
way we're gonna do it we're gonna follow
these rules so to speak you will help
your child to actually be able to stay
calm and let them voice to you their
concerns all good advice dr. Gail Saltz
thank you